come on if the Call of Duty franchise is
a well-oiled machine the black ops 3 is
the replacement part that keeps the
wheels moving into yet another year it
introduces minor changes to an
established formula and in some aspects
this is developer Treyarch near its feet
but in others call of duty black ops 3
lacks inspirations
Treyarch has set a high bar with its
contributions to the Call of Duty series
but here with call of duty black ops 3
it reaches in several different
directions with vastly different results
the newest iteration of multiplayer
begins on a promising note as black ops
3 specialists cover the screen these are
the soldiers of humanity's future clad
in titanium alloy armor brandishing
multimillion-dollar weapons they're also
black ops 3 s new layer of customization
we still have the traditional loadout
system with 10 slots to spend on weapons
items and equipment but specialists add
a little more nuance with these
characters you're forced to choose
between a power weapon or special
ability as only one can be equipped at a
time and the dichotomy between these two
as well as the possibilities their uses
reveal leads to some dynamic scenarios
from one match to the next certain
powers work well in specific game types
and can shift momentum when used well
and for the first several hours in black
ops 3 s multiplayer I explored as many
possibilities as I could but that sense
of discovery fades with time black ops 3
grants you access to four specialists
out of the gate and subsequent options
unlock in a trickle but there's too much
time between them to keep things moving
along and when I'm not learning the
intricacies of a new character black ops
3 defaults to a more generic Call of
Duty experience this isn't necessarily a
bad thing in fact black ops 3
multiplayer offers some of the best map
designs in the franchise each arena is a
confluence of differing sight lines
hectic clash points and diverse
elevations the new movement system also
creates an action reaction dynamic you
can wall run in to capture points ground
slide out of firefights and clamber over
ledges otherwise out of reach in short
black ops 3 is fluid it just feels good
but it's lack of variety after about 10
hours he races much of the excitement
present at the beginning there's still
the proverbial carrot dangling on a
string in front of us it's just smaller
this time around
your enemy knows Bravo
then there's black ops 3 s new zombies
map shadows of evil it's pure survival
set in a jazzy fictional city complete
with slipspace portals and Cthulhu like
monsters make no mistake this new
version of zombies is bizarre it's also
fantastic there's a looming sense of
mystery as you decide which doors to
unlock next which weapons prove most
effective and what that glowing green
plant even does the difficulty is high
here but zombies now more than ever is a
learning experience and seeing the
tangible results of your practice is
rewarding the undead horde has also
wandered its way into another game mode
it's called nightmares and it unlocks
once you've beaten the campaign
basically Treyarch recycled black ops 3
campaign missions but now with zombies
and a grim voiceover from an unnamed
character and believe it or not this
works there's a slower pace to the
missions here and in reimagining the
story to center around a zombie
infection
Treyarch has created something
magnitudes better than its vanilla
campaign you've been made Hendrix what's
the call
now
Plan B Plan B in contrast to nightmares
the original campaign is a chore it's a
boring crawl that wastes no time
throwing you into its routine you're
thrust into tidal waves of enemies and
fun will be linear pathways on the way
to your next objective there are some
deviations from this pattern but I was
already on autopilot by the fifth
mission settled into a continual routine
of aim shoot reload three-peat there are
fleeting moments when the new cybernetic
modifications changed the way you play
the campaign these abilities let you
control enemy drones stun human
opponents or set fire to robots internal
systems the powers would be more
impactful though if there wasn't such a
lack of enemy variety by and large the
enemy variants just require differing
number of bullets to take down and when
you're using them on such a repetitive
group of targets who react the same way
every time the abilities lose their
novelty black ops 3s narrative doesn't
support the campaign in any way either
it tells an incomprehensible story about
AI ascendancy and the moral greys of a
hyper-connected future raising
intriguing questions but never bothering
to answer them and as it closes the
campaign ends not with a bang but a
whimper in its undead modes and the
first ten hours of multiplayer call of
duty black ops 3 excels but in its
campaign it merely crawls forward black
ops 3 doesn't offer anything remarkable
to the series doing just enough to
maintain the Call of Duty status quo the
franchise however slowly continues its
steady march you could not be here
Taylor Taylor I want to get out of here